how's it going citizens of the reject
nation it is jon here but we're mixing
it up this week i am joined by our good
friend and co-reject salamander sally
lamonico how you doing sally what's up
i'm doing great john thanks for asking i
feel like i'm on a talk show that's good
that's good there's going to be a few
minutes of jokes we should have a couch
set up
pre-prepared questions for you mugs i
can drink out of one day your face on it
we'll have a proprietary mug but uh
thank you for joining me today i've been
i've been looking forward to this movie
for a long time it's a movie that i
certainly missed when it was first out
but i remember people at least talking
about i have almost no knowledge of
anything to do with this other than like
a few of the cast and the director and
the word multi-pass so this is going to
be a good kind of illuminating
experience for me i just know i've seen
mia yoba bitch's character from this
movie
countless cosplays like everywhere
especially i had red hair for a while so
people like you should be her and i'm
like i've never seen the movie so well
hey after today you'll have your new
requisite cosplay so guys hit that like
button leave a comment on the video with
your thoughts on the movie also don't
forget to subscribe turn on that
notification bell so you can get
notified any time one of these movie
reactions is out or anything else you
might be interested in if you want to
get the full experience alongside us
bring your own copy over to our patreon
page patreon.com the real reject sync up
with the time code enjoy the whole movie
as well as all of our other different
shows and flicks we watch over there
last but not least thank you to the team
over at prepper huge huge help in
editing these highlights down choosing
all the best moments they are
instrumental in the process visit our
shop zero edition.com store if you like
my hat let's do it let's hop in the
fifth element you ready sally yeah i
want a real rejects hat i need to get
one well you have to pay for one because
i will gladly
no we'll get you one all right let's hop
in
[Music]
[Music]
what a fun life these kids must have
desert life
is life
this is light
good
rest in peace luke perry yeah i was
about to say
when is the snake act supposed to occur
every five thousand years
so i've got some time
you bring them over
good boy
i will take you to them go with god be
safe from evil imagine someone said that
every time you leave be safe from evil
i was gonna say every time i give
somebody a task i just wanted to say go
with god be safe from evil
bring me a sandwich
we already know too much
what
is he going to poison them it looks like
it
they know too much
i'm going to be famous
let us toast your vape
to fame
if anyone looks at you like that when
you're about to drink something totally
could you be more
[Music]
that was a creepy shot yeah
great use of shadows
whoa
what
oh my god
sketch it all luke perry
cause i'll never believe your story
[Music]
oh god
this looks like what did i do
i'll never
sleep on the light again
priest you and those before you have
served us well
but war is coming stones not safe on
earth anymore
they say stones aren't safe yeah
they probably gotta remove all this
well
this
is really amazing
[Music]
that's what they said when they opened
al capone's vault
[Music]
i would lose my mind if i saw that in
person
i know right
and it's the most jarringly designed
sarcophagus just that like wrenched up
open
mouth years when evil returns
so shall we i'd be like well i'll be
dead so
good luck with that yeah you know
next generation will deal with it you
still have time time not important only
life important
[Music]
dang poor alien dude what
that is my biggest fear
yeah
look at that lightning effect
evil begets evil mr president
shooting will only make it stronger
probably attains objective in five
seconds
whoa
what happened oh dang this tiny lister
better can you hear me you hit her
what happened sketter did you destroy me
i'm about to sir
just give me a minute yeah just like
chill bro let it do its thing it's
moving towards the ship
what what do we have that's bigger than
240 nothing sir
get out of there i don't want an
incident do you hear me
get out
[Music]
what did he think was gonna happen
[Music]
that was scary
that was cool
[Laughter]
all right i'm gonna wait for five
seconds and i'm already cool
okay i'm pretty sweet
[Music]
how many points you got left on your
license
at least 50.
you know what you gotta learn how to lie
better see you tonight
i appreciate that his cigarettes like
all filter
right
i was thinking that too
what are you smoking z140
alleviated titanium no charge assault
model yeah yeah
good thing for me it's not loaded
i have to push that little yellow button
to load it
this guy is actively crapping his pants
right now yeah
you don't mind do you no you're sure oh
take it
i don't need it
where did they fight this guy i don't
know
yes yes
no matter where you are in the future
fuzzy dice yeah yep the fuzzy dice will
always be relevant
you have five points left on your
license thank you for reminding me
that's way better than 50 points
oh my goodness
there's almost like a jim henson
equality to some of these creatures
good i'll meet you at my factory
there there are so many accents in this
movie
you see normal human beings have 40 dna
memo groups which is more than enough
for any species to perpetuate itself
this has 200 thousand memo groups
science
yes science
sounds like a freaking nature whoa
yeah
can't wait to meet him god
oh yeah
it's a good black light poster to be
made there
[Music]
[Music]
it's like 3d printing before it was a
thing
and honestly like the mix of like
practical things and and miniatures and
cg isn't bad
it's pretty good for like
an older movie actually yeah it's like
the mid 90s i want to say i mean that
looks like cg
yeah it's a little bit of a playstation
but uh
reconstruction
complete
remove the shield
oh dang
it's a girl
this is blurred
it's blurred
i know
i like to take a few pictures oh jesus
i'm sure time for copy my dude
upward dog
she invented yoga
[Music]
yeah i was going to say though like this
is a good physical performance because
that must hurt
i'd feel so claustrophobic filming that
you went out
you're going to have to learn to develop
those communication skills
oh no
that's freaky i'm not gonna lie
whoa
what
kool-aid man
this way
whoa
why don't we have flying cars
i'm so conflicted because part of me is
like we should never have flying cars
yeah that's true
but then again you see stuff like this
and you're like but that looks awesome
i would vomit
yeah that would be freaking terrifying i
hate heights
i think we need a flying unit here
[Laughter]
[Music]
she has no file
[Music]
aah
such a cool way to bring him back into
the story i wasn't even thinking about
it
any survivors
you okay
[Laughter]
we're in new york
unit 47 we're on the way
as soon as we finish lunch
future mcdonald's
[Music]
hang on
i like the quirky like loungy jazz
classical soundtrack i know i was like
i'm really this is interesting it's like
90s bossa nova yeah right it's kind of a
cool thing
for a hover car
police chase yeah it's different
imagine
imagine
i do have almost no idea how she hasn't
been like splattered all over the
backseat by now oh my god
[Music]
what
yes
speaking of looking for a priest the
wedding's at one floor down my son
congratulations
mazel tov buddy she's got a
tattoo on this arm here
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh the lighting's perfect
i woke her up you're right i shouldn't
have done that
what is your name
you
corbin
[Laughter]
can i get a business card
yeah
shorter name
sure
[Laughter]
lilu
that's cute
[Music]
father are you sure she's a supreme
being absolutely sure look at how hot
she is
she's a ran out of courgette supreme i
was on my way over to see you when a big
fare fell on my lap
you know one of these really big fares
that you just can't resist
oh
[Music]
the last 5 000 years that she's missed
he's been asleep for quite a while you
know
yes
downloaded all neo
wow
father i know she's been through a lot
we don't have much time
i thought i was gonna say we don't have
much chicken
at this rate she's gonna go through the
entire city
[Music]
oh wow
yeah the case
with the stones
where is it
stolen
they wondered it'd be possible to fire
500 000 fire 1 million but 500 thousands
[Music]
oh that soul patch
the original low key
yeah no not a bad call
they really make her perfect
i know cornelius except kiba
taba
um what did she say
this was back when you could get away
with like
semi-innocuous nudity in pg-13 movies
you're worried speak proud
so what if the federal government
scattered your people to the wind what
doesn't kill you
makes you stronger
your time for revenge is at hand
voila
do every southern american accent at
once 3 000 round flip with bursts of
three to 300 with the replay button
another zorg invention it's even easier
oh one shot
and replay sends every following shot to
the same location
what
rocket launcher
arrow launcher
with explosive poisonous gas head
oh ow
the always official flamethrower
jesus
that
is crazy my favorite
this case is empty
[Laughter]
the guardians
gave the stones to someone that they
could trust
you supposed to contact this person
in a hotel
brilliant
she's looking for the address
she's so good with the alien language
yeah
that's very believable
what the hell am i supposed to do with
an empty case
you can still count
zero stones
zero crates
pack everything up we're out of here
oh
dang
that seems like a button you'd want to
have on a gun
now take this empty glass here it is
peaceful but if it is
destroyed so busy now notice how this
one is useful
thus adding to the great chain
of life
what
he's really good at this character
i'm in fact encouraging life
you and i are in the same business
cherish
that was an interesting monologue yeah
[Music]
[Music]
i want a cactus button on my desk
the best desk of all time
how your entire empire of destruction
comes
crashing down
all because of one little
wreckage stones weren't aboard the ship
what do you mean the mondo chiwa never
fully trusted the human race
oh
all we have to do is send someone to get
excellent
why would you get that close
yeah you don't think he's gonna notice
little i guess he didn't but
if he got a good look at it he'd see the
little microphone bugged they were being
bugged
great dad joke
i appreciate that they used an actual
roach for that yeah that was cute it
made it kind of cute yeah
yeah just give a roach backpack stunt
wrote i wonder if he's in the credits
maybe there there are rules for like
insect actors
you got broken fingers you can't punch
my number hi mom 17 messages don't tell
me your machine is broken again those
things are good for 1000 years mr kim
you should go this is going to take a
minute you wouldn't even feed your white
boys if food could fly up to my window
oh my god dude in 300 years that's what
grubhub is gonna be
oh my god this is gonna be a traveling
restaurant
yeah sure
whoa
cool that's so cool
as a member of the elite special forces
unit of the federated army you're an
expert in the use of all weapons and
spacecraft needed for this mission
who is it
um
my wife you're remarried not live no i
just met this girl but i'm gonna marry
her i love her but she hates the
military she knows at the military rule
my last marriage is she can't have
anything to do with it if she sees you
guys here she's gonna kill me major look
just you gotta hide somewhere you gotta
help me you just gotta hide somewhere
we'd love to help but i mean there's
only one door where can we hide
he's a g
three of us will fit in there sure
so that's a great thing about about a
90s movie like this you you have these
random wacky side breaks
control don't touch anything this
is a yellow
the claustrophobia i would have yeah
right
sir can you put your hands in the yellow
circles
is please tent
[Music]
but of course
oh
white shirt and what this can't be a 90s
movie it's the next logical step from
that bandage outfit she had
did you hear something
oh
no
oh
god what
really figuring
out
oh
that seems like a very realistic
reaction
oh
i'll take the mission
are they dead i know are they are they
dead or just frozen
i don't know i hope they're not like
hibernation
congratulations on winning the contest
oh right okay sorry for the mess i was
so afraid i wasn't going to make this
flight so i sent uh david here to come
and pick up my boarding pass but now
david has to go thank you
bye
lilu dallas multipass
multiple she knows it's a multi-path
leela dallas my wife we're newlyweds
just met you know how it is bumping to
each other sparks happen yeah she knows
it's a multi-pass yeah anyway we're in
love
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh this yeah not possible you want some
more this is all my fault
it's my mission i should never have
given it to you i know
it's the key to the temple prepare for
our arrival no don't to come on yeah
oh no dude don't mess this up
corbin dollas
yeah that's me
um
just a minute please
everyone's corbin dallas today
great honor to be on his talk show
he's so grateful yes i'm sure you're
very excited but i'm on my vacation i
don't want to be bothered
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
i'm having so many so many feelings
right now
uh same this sequence is brought to you
by cocaine and ecstasy
i feel like this is little nausea
good call
but i know it's not
this is montero truly this is one
so tomorrow from five to seven will you
please act like you have more than a two
word vocabulary
i didn't come here to play pumbaa on the
radio so tomorrow from five to seven
you're gonna give yourself a hand
green
football
i am court medalist sorry sir boarding
is spinning
hey
i wish you could do that in retail i
know i was gonna say that must be the
most satisfying thing for for the
service industry
yes this
fifth element
supreme being
me protect you
sleep
it's like what happened to my mask kill
in a day for a second
[Music]
i appreciate this wacky attention to
detail
ray i'm like okay they're really putting
a lot into this scene what would it
really be like getting a intergalactic
flight ready
it is to be too
disappointed one sorry sir this will
never happen again i don't know
liftoff
oh my god
imagine oh my god
imagine
my
costs have tripled
money
is
no
importance
that's what happened to that other guy
right before he died
yeah
[Music]
i'll see you personally
parasites and main ventilation
again don't worry i'll get it
tell me my man
are you happy
[Music]
boring
here
it's a subconscious message
mm-hmm
play it backwards
yeah
search what's in your memories
everybody's here
spy kids
reminds me of a twilight and a xenomorph
had a baby
[Music]
okay get down
yeah now it's a hip opera
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
oh i'm getting out of here
and he's like bye
nope
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
got
him no security works at this hotel
yeah i'm like how do they get past with
that
no
no no
what oh i don't like that
it's the day the music died
let's
change the weight
is he gonna put on caught night joe the
supreme being sent to her to save the
universe she needs your help
and your love
ah
can't die come on listen to me wake up
where are the stones
what the stones where are the stones
the stones
they're not in the box inside her
yeah probably
oh
oh
what
cut her open yeah
it's a saw movie now
oh
[Music]
oh my god
ow
that hurt me i know he's gotta have
broken glass like all up in his arms
don't stop live streaming dude
no
that's pretty accurate
wait a minute wait a minute
i think he's trying to say something to
me
count two
ten
this movie i keep i keep thinking like
how much higher can his voice go
he goes for yeah
how many oxygen i love that because that
would be me
no not the priest that's the leader i've
never negotiated
you mind if i
try no no sure
[Music]
oh
cold
nice shot
sorry sir you can't stay here there's a
bomb in the hotel
i know
[Laughter]
i know
just like driving a kid
[Music]
nice
in movies being a cabbie can prepare you
for anything
yes
[Music]
[Music]
wow
jesus
[Music]
imagine that glass just like
oh dude you gotta be cooking in there
i know there's a ball of fires 1200
miles diameter heading straight for
earth and we have no idea how to stop it
how much time do we have
if it's speed remains constant
in an hour and 57 minutes
i'll call you back in two hours
oh no
what a boss
don't do this to yourself lilu
[Music]
she's really good in this
yeah she's phenomenal
how do you open these stones
don't die now
we're never going to make it
cry on it
like entangled
corbin yeah corbin it moved would you
talk someone you did tell me what you
did he breathed on it
oh
each element needs its element
clever
whoa
there you go oh smart okay
cool
for a second i thought i was gonna be
like aquaman should we should we pee on
it
i have no fire
i have no matches
you're all fire baby oh he's got
cigarettes
yes
the one time smoking saved the universe
all for christ's sake just drop it on it
the love of god
oh
oh thank goodness
that was so dramatic
very nice things worth saving some
beautiful things beautiful things
everything before w
yes love that's good that's good that's
a good example like love love is worth
saving
i don't know love oh
you're wrong you're wrong you're wrong
i need you
i need you very much loving is a part of
protecting
because i love you say it
because i love you
[Music]
wow
dang
the original sky beam
she did it before godzilla that's right
scanner imaging has confirmed
planet seems to have stopped at 62 miles
from impact
the sweat oh my god
i think that would be my response
mrs dallas
this is the president it doesn't even
sound like him the president's an idiot
and you don't sound like an idiot if you
don't want to talk to your mother just
avoid me like usual huh i'll just throw
myself in traffic i'll just saran wrap
myself
jesus
they brought her back her voice they did
i wonder if that's like a voice cameo
[Music]
oh yeah
nice
dang
we did it
are there post-credit scenes
i doubt it
given the the time and place we're in
but you know let me see if they um
listed the cockroach yeah
and the cockroach trainer
cockroach wrangler should have been up
top
yeah that was impressive
that's real though like i was watching
there's a movie called uh i think it's
called a kingdom of the spiders or
something with uh oh they didn't they
didn't have the roads
it's messed up
i know no yeah there was a movie called
kingdom of the spiders with uh william
shatner where they had like
so they had like tons and tons and tons
of tarantulas that you could tell were
real and you could tell that they were
like driving over and smashing with
props
really
yeah and as much as you know
most people are probably like good or
something like that that movie set a
precedent where they were like okay now
we have to have actual insect wranglers
so that you're not just like massacring
tons and tons and tons of insects on
camera right because that's unethical
yeah it's fascinating so you know that
roach probably had a trainer
absolutely i bet it did but he killed it
he did an amazing job totally there's
got to be a roach actors union
a roach actors union yeah
a rag wreck welcome to rag the roach
actor's killed
i think we're probably good
i'm just gonna skip around a little bit
just uh not to slight all the lovely
people who did incredible work who made
this movie congratulations yes
always gotta check
yeah in this day and age can never be
too safe
never
not with zorg no no
for zorg
he was just a cog
why did he have a thick southern accent
you know
so good just just cuz just cause like
the i like these like space operatic
ensembles especially in the 90s where
it's like you kind of have the freedom
to cast whoever because it's just like a
big mixed you know intergalactic
integrated world it was i will say the
most unique movie i've seen in a really
really long time
yeah it really was and it's funny like
parts of it were what i expected and and
parts of it
weren't especially right and kind of how
it moves and how it treats its
characters and stuff like that because
you see like you know you think bruce
willis moving you're like okay so he's
gonna be like you know like we
referenced john mclean during the
reaction you think like okay he's gonna
be john mcclane and like he has his his
bruce willis chic and all that but like
it really is an ensemble movie yeah i
well seeing them all at the end trying
to figure out the elements and how they
could work i just had a thought of like
wow this is a very unique cast
like at the end yeah seeing it all come
together with the singer and then the
assistant and then the priest and i just
was like that's so unique i i haven't
really it reminded me of guardians a
little bit yeah definitely there's
definitely some of that in here or some
of this in guardians yeah yeah but then
there's also like a grunginess to this
movie that i feel like has been missing
from a lot of sci-fi movies yeah like it
it does have that sort of like sprawling
like you're seeing a bunch of different
locations and you're seeing like the
slummy parts versus the super luxe and
ritzy parts and it has that like cyber
punk like especially when yeah yeah when
you're in like the city where bruce
willis lives like it looks like a yeah
like a crappier version of the world
from blade runner or something kind of
reminded me too of a little bit of like
ready player one and some visuals yeah i
guess
but i was like this one just felt really
90s it was fun it was really fun it was
different yeah like it had like there
were times where it would kind of dip
into that i feel like the 90s the 80s
and the 90s both had this sort of like
cocaine-fueled zaniness that they would
dip into and the 90s has its sort of own
advanced version of that and and this
definitely had that but i also like that
there was a certain amount i was about
to say element and i feel like
i was
really feeling it and then you didn't
say it
there's a certain element of of yeah
like
cartoon it's like it's cartoony in the
right way for the most part where it's
like you know yeah for like all of act
three you have chris tucker
just like along for the ride just like
yelling and narrating and it's like it's
silly but it also
works in an odd way for just the
situation
yeah
because there were so many serious
moments and he would always cut the
tension
but i also felt like he would probably
be like the regular person in that
situation as well and how they would
react yeah and i feel like
it's this movie has so many elements
that could easily i feel like go wrong
and somehow it's really fun like the
cast
like even the cat like everybody
shows up and like
if i felt like the casting was really
intentional because not everybody is
giving like the most
like the performances vary and some of
the smaller characters are pretty wooden
but in a charming way you know like i
would agree with that
um i feel like leela lily
lee lou
um
she probably had the hardest job as an
actor on this set i feel like everyone
else got to have fun and she was
probably just really going through it
uh yeah a lot of her scenes i feel like
were really emotional and intense and
everyone else
had a lot of fun and i just felt bad for
her
as an actress i know
because i mean she's she has to go
through kind of everything here and i i
love the way she played it because like
yeah it is a really physical role and
they're constantly making her like
change in and out of these like tiny
costumes and stuff but like yeah that
first step
yeah she does a really a really good job
of of playing
sort of an otherworldly character but
still having a certain kind of just
innate charm about her and like an
innocence yeah i feel like they they had
her kind of be a little childlike in the
beginning and just kind of like learning
everything and i don't know that
was interesting but then she's also very
uh intelligent so it was just really
interesting to have that yeah portrayal
yeah absolutely and and two like it's i
feel like it it always deserves
an extra amount of credit when you have
to do that thing of like
yeah you have the childlike quality and
you also have this sort of animal
quality where
yeah it's like that that first scene
where you know she's first waking up in
her body and she's like writhing in the
tube
yeah yeah it's like you know and and
and the little nuances like when she is
like learning all of human war and and
she has to sort of conjure up the
emotional like i imagine as an actor
it's hard to put yourself
you know you gotta gotta work to meet
the fantasy elements halfway and to make
those emotional yeah like i thought she
she hit all the right notes across this
yeah she nailed it for sure um i there
was a lot more comedy in this movie than
i was expecting i was expecting some
like really big serious like sci-fi
movie but um this had way more comedy
than i expected and i enjoyed that yeah
and i i i think this is is this based on
a comic book or something like that
because it that would make sense that
was my next question like it was is
there source material before this movie
because it was so unique i was like how
did someone come up with all of this i
know yeah and they're still and you know
they're obviously like elements like
there are a couple of
again take a drink every time we say
elements but but yeah like they cut out
there are a couple of those establishing
shots in space of the giant uh you know
ships surveying the ever-growing like
black void
and yeah and those like look straight
out of star wars and things like that
and yeah
there's a lot probably there's like you
know a certain amount of sci-fi salad
but i feel like this had a really uh
nice sized salad yeah you know you can
you can point out all sorts of different
influences but i really liked the way
that this
i think the thing that separates this
for me
from a lot of other you know space opera
ensemble movies is that that sense of
fun and the way it moves in the way that
like the situation is the unifying
factor you know like the need to
assemble the stones and get the fifth
element in the middle and you know
create this world-saving beacon you know
but everybody else around that like it
doesn't really cut to anyone i guess you
know you could say lilo and bruce willis
are technically the protagonists but
yeah in a way
you're cutting between so many people
that yeah it more it feels like there's
like way more protagonists and
antagonists yeah like it really
a lot
totally it feels like a true ensemble
piece that way
but yeah i feel like i'm still
processing the movie
sorry no because it is like it is a lot
and it is an onslaught and it's it's
it's cool too because again like
nowadays with the movies we have you're
sort of conditioned i think to expect a
certain amount of like there's there's a
ton of action in this movie
but it doesn't feel like it orchestrates
the action scenes quite the way like if
this was made today i would have a
different set of expectations as to what
the action would be like and stuff like
that
right because so much of this you are
watching like for a lot of it bruce
willis like is kind of just like having
his own day and his own situation and he
gradually gets pulled into this
and i like that and i like that yeah
you're kind of seeing a lot of how just
life is 300 years or you know
i guess from where we are now it's about
200 years in the future
um
and yeah just like the
it has
both all the adventure and fun and sort
of sci-fi mumbo jumbo you want you know
you got the mcguffins that are the
stones and you've got all these
different groups who are trying to get
to the stones
um but yeah i don't know it seems like
they really took time for their
production designs and to really make
the world feel real and feel lived in
it it was really solid a few a few like
visuals also reminded me of
artificial intelligence a little bit as
well
um
like when specifically
when
uh the little boy meets joe yeah and
they're in that kind of futuristic world
um
anyway that just visually but um
i'm sure i'm sure like they they drew
from that the mixture of i liked how
many practical
effects and practical prosthetics and
everything there were in this movie
because it was just super impressive i
don't know i felt like i was more drawn
like more interested in this
um watching this and not getting
sidetracked or anything um because a lot
of it you could tell was was like real
makeup and prosthetics and i just find
that really interesting to watch oh
totally um
and
real puppets too like all those yeah the
big alien gang who is so fun yeah right
it's fun to watch
and i love that you know like gary oman
has to spend like half his time with
those characters and like you know he's
taking like i love that it's like you
can tell you know he's bringing his a
game he's taking it seriously but also
he's he's such a sort of strange wacky
character
and he always
i just kept thinking about on his
character and true romance i was too
like this this does feel like there was
that period of time especially during
the 90s where it's like we got to have
gary oldman as our our arch eccentric
villain yes and
just let him do whatever he wants and
he'll do great
yeah it's one of those things where
where in a way it seems like everybody
was chosen to do their quintessential
thing and and that's a testament to i
guess the casting is specifically
because yeah it feels like very
intentional the way everybody was chosen
here
yeah that i can see why this movie is a
classic it's just a hundred percent got
that quality yeah and it's kind of hard
to put your finger on like like yeah see
something with a tone like this
like that
pulling off a tone like this now
would be so hard
uh
i just because i you're right when you
mentioned how formulaic everything is
right now um
i think we're just used to a certain
style at the moment um and so
if someone tried to pull off a movie
like like this now
it would be really hard the closest
thing i could think of is like jojo
rabbit in terms of like the the tone and
the editing and the directing
yeah it was very different and this kind
of reminded me of kind of the spot the
i don't know the tone was just uh fun
and different but it also was serious at
times and
the ending i could see being really
cheesy but i really enjoyed it because
the rest of the movie wasn't cheesy so i
feel like it still was pulled off really
well but to do that to have an ending
like that now i'm like i don't think
would work as well you know
yeah like i i think yeah because it's
like you buy their romance even though
like that's not what most of the story
is about but it's got enough
i think it's something to do with the
fact that
it's like if this were made now i would
be afraid that it would be bogged down
and having to be meta because there's
something about
watching this where i'm like there is a
certain amount of kookiness and zaniness
and it's
even though it doesn't take itself too
seriously yeah it seems like it takes
itself just seriously enough and it
knows well enough to to say that okay
this world is a little over the top
anyway and so that's what works and
there are times where yeah there are
these like
moments that feel like
a random comedy bit but then there are a
lot of other things that just feel like
yeah this is just kind of a strange
world and i think that people
underestimate
how much that can transport you in a
movie like this and i feel like that's
what a lot of things don't
do as much now things are i almost feel
like a lot of movies now
are trying to make you laugh but are
afraid to be the weird kid
okay yeah that makes sense yeah where's
a movie like this i don't feel like you
go too far out there
yeah they don't want to lose you yeah
they don't take risks anymore is what
you're saying yeah like comedic risks
yeah i don't know there's something
about it it may be not the best metaphor
but it just reminds me of like improv
classes where i'm like
you gotta be willing to get a little
stupid sometimes and to not be afraid of
that because that can be very freeing
you know right no it looks like everyone
felt freaked in this movie yeah i
enjoyed it that was super fun yeah
yeah i'm glad we got to watch this
together too this was a good shared
experience i really appreciate the music
that's the other thing the music oh my
god yes
very unique very unique soundtrack and i
love very nineties
very nineties
in a way that feels like absolutely that
but also i'm like i'm not used to
hearing soundtracks exactly yeah there
was a if there was a few like one moment
specifically was technically really
serious but the music was so out there
that it like obviously brought the tone
back up but i was like i bet these
actors when they watched the movie were
like huh like that's not what i was
imagining there's like saxophones but
i'm crying
you know right
and and again it's that's that's the
thing too is like there are these
there's these choices that feel
odd but right i guess yeah and and two
like that's another thing about the
world i think that's smart is like you
said it with this music that is familiar
but it's like crashing styles together
you wouldn't expect and that kind of
gives
it lends credence to just like the
transport of whimsies it's ballsy
yeah i've seen film moments ruined with
the wrong music before 100 percent
that they somehow pulled it off yeah i
mean that's part of movie matt like
that's part of movie magic is like you
can
see a cut 12 different ways and and once
you get the right music under it like it
all can come together or it can all be
completely different you know depending
on on a music cue change
and and i love too
that the opera
like as much as he's like i don't want
to go on this freaking vacation this is
so conspicuous and then they go see the
opera and everyone is like so moved
i was moving i was like sick girl i know
it was like a it was a beautiful moment
and it's things like that where it's
like that's not i think two nowadays
there's a certain like economics of plot
where it's like we always got to be kind
of focused on the point and i'm like
yeah i think there's something in that
where it's like yeah this is all you
know things are coming down to the wire
everything's coming to a head the stones
are somewhere here and something to do
with this opera performance is involved
but also everyone's experiencing the
opera i felt like i was watching it with
them yeah it took me on that journey
with the characters and i appreciated
that yeah it's like you don't have to do
that especially for an element like this
had they skipped that and she just like
got shot for example like right off the
bat i'm like that we wouldn't have felt
it as much but because we like actually
got to enjoy her singing and got you
know
was in the moment and then she got shot
i was like no
i know
i was like yeah i've only just met you
and yet somehow i feel like we've
suffered a great loss i know
so that was that was brilliant
and and and props to her for getting all
those stones in there and still being
able to sing
yeah to sing while having a bunch of
stones on her and to tell him
before she died
what was gonna happen where they are
oh man yeah that was a ride this was a
ride man and this was yeah i mean
i feel like you look back and a lot of
times are given cause to be like man
they just don't make stuff like this
anymore no but they i felt nostalgic
watching it for some reason even though
i've never seen it before it gave me
like nostalgia i get what you mean it's
yeah it's funny it's like this felt
fresh in a lot of ways and even a lot of
the effects have aged decently well or
even if they haven't you're like but
i don't know you could just tell like
man for the time though that must have
been impressive right right and like i i
don't mean to harp on the ending because
it was cheesy i thought it was cute
that's what i meant it was cute yeah
it was cute
that's the thing is like there's there's
world rending stakes but there's also
some really i'd ever seen bruce willis
say lines like that how do you
no
no it's like that's the perfect because
yeah it's the blend of he's got the like
you know new york cab driver he's yeah
he's got the bruce willis attitude but
then it's balanced out with that other
[ __ ] softy in this movie i liked it
he just wanted to find love man
yeah
and to get his mom off his back
that was funny well at details like that
too i'm like they didn't need to do that
they didn't need to do that but they did
and it was funny yeah it feels like a
very like 90s thing like they're like
you can tell this this feels like
the same era yeah like that 80s 90s
thing that like robocop almost has or
something yeah or it's just like oh
there's these random they they give the
characters a little more life outside of
i feel like nowadays the the goal is
like give them like a family member or
some core trauma that's easy to relate
to and then go
i love how i was like yeah because i've
seen posters i've never actually seen
robocop
oh
that is a great movie so i should react
to that i'm sad i can't watch it with
you on camera because that is a great
movie and that movie holds up
never seen robocop i've never seen
terminator
oh my goodness gracious oh you got some
but i did the 3d ride at universal and i
was so confused
that's great you should you should yeah
you should not see any other terminator
just just t2 3d that's it
terminator terminated
oh man well you got some stuff to look
forward to i i'm i'm excited for you
some people are like how could you i'm
like no you got a journey ahead that's
that's awesome no they're just jealous
you know yeah yeah they don't get to
experience it for the first time again
well any any any residual thoughts on
fifth element before we
fold each other up into the internet
isn't the fifth element technically
plasma
let's google it really quick
is plastic that's what i thought was
gonna happen that the lava from the
planet was gonna come down and hit her
and then everything was gonna be fine
oh if they combined or something like
that
that's what i thought was gonna happen
fifth state of matter or fourth state
state of matter sorry
is plasma the fourth element
the plasma sorry the fourth state of
matter that's what it is it's not
elements
scientist sally that's your nickname
everyone calls you
even though yeah and now we just have
another moon i guess floating around
yeah just a dead energy sucking moon
yes
those tides are going crazy yeah
yeah
that's what fifth element two is about
it's gonna become water world yep
water world plus space we gotta fix the
tides
earth is flooded
yeah
oh that's good
well
pledge allegiance to president tiny
lister leave us your comments down below
what you think of the movie anything you
want to enlighten us on i'm sure there's
something
i'm sure there's something that's
retroactively become a meme that we
could be hip to
any any parting words for the people
salamander
you pka [ __ ] yippie kaye thank
you guys for joining us leave a like
comment subscribe all that stuff and we
will catch you next time people
bye peace
[Music]